Let's go back to our list of concepts and say what have we done so far and what's next?
We think we did a good job with the dictionary,
and we did a good job with our hands here.
In terms of legal play, well, we've got words, so we're sort of part way there,
but we haven't hooked up the words to the board.
Maybe that's the next thing to do--is say, let's do a better job of hooking up
the letters and the hand with the words in the dictionary
and placing them in the right place on the board.
I don't want to have to deal with the whole board. Let's just deal with one letter at a time.
Let's say there is one letter on the board,
and I have my hand and I want to say I can play W-O-R and make up a word.
Just to make it a little bit more satisfying than one letter,
let's say that there is a set of possible letters that are already on the board,
and we can place our words anywhere,
but we're not going to worry about placing some letters here and having them run off the board.
We're not going to worry about placing letters here and having them run into another letter.
We're just going to say what words can I make out of my hand that connect
with either a D or an X or an L.
So I need a strategy for that. Let's just consider one letter at a time.
What I need to find is all the plays that take letters in my hand--
[HANDSIE] let's say those are the seven letters in my hand.
Take those letters and combine them with a D and find all the words.
What can those words consist of?
They can have some prefix here, which can be any prefix in our set of prefixes
that come solely from the letters in my hand.
Then the letter D that's already there doesn't have to come from my hand.
Then some more letters.
I'll think of this as a prefix plus a suffix where I make sure that I know that D is already there.
Here is word-plays--takes a hand and a set of letters that are on the board,
and it's going t o find all possible words that can be made from that hand,
connecting to exactly one of the letters on the board.
We're going break it up into a prefix that comes only from the hand,
then the letter from the board, and then the remainder of the suffix that comes from the hand.
The same structure as we had before--we start off with an empty set of result words.
In the end we're going to return that set of result words.
Then we're going to go through all the possible prefixes that come exclusively from the hand,
then the possible letters on the board, and add a suffix to the prefix plus the letter on the board
from the letters in the hand except for we can no longer use the letters in the prefix.
Find_prefixes is just like find_words except we're collecting things that are in the prefixes
rather than things that are in the list of words.
Now I want you to write add_suffixes.
Given a hand, a prefix that we found before, results set that you want to put things into,
find me all the words that can be made by adding on letters from the hand
into the prefix to create words.